are you happy that Elon is finally
buying Twitter
yo I love Elon he's a billion I never
met Elon I don't know what you know why
I'm asking I'll be doing I don't know
why you asked me I will tell you why
every question I ask has a it's like
we're playing ping pong you see yeah
you're trying to set me up to make me
look a certain way for your baby let me
tell you you what's the purpose but let
me tell you this here's what I'm willing
I'm willing to turn hear me out hear me
out hear me out let me tell you what I'm
willing to do I want to turn off the
mics not record not go live with it just
have a conversation with you did you
hear what I just said hear me on what I
just said fair for the business but but
I totally get set that side aside
money's money I don't care about money
if you want to set aside the mic and we
just have a combo I'm open to it bro and
we turn up all the cameras
because you just said to me the only
reason is I'm trying to stroke you too
much I don't know about Twitter
pauler bro you asking sure I don't know
Elon Musk man I respect Elon Musk he's a
billionaire I respect him but I don't
know him I don't know why he bought the
Twitter I know Kanye just bought Paula
that's all I know but do you know why
why I don't know man I don't know him
may I State why I asked the question so
are you asking me questions that don't
pertain to like you know but this is
what you call a conversation and you
said you like a conversation a dialogue
that's a dialogue
man because you feeling uncomfortable
you like talking about the mic's off cut
the cameras off dude I've sat down with
Mobsters I've sat down with gang I've
sat down I'm just military I've sat down
with everybody very little makes me
uncomfortable but if I may I'll let you
know why I asked that question you said
cancel culture cancel culture is a
concern for a lot of people the idea
they just asked me about Elon Musk but
Elon Musk Buy in Twitter is good for
those where they won't feel like they're
gonna be canceled who was those anybody
that so who getting cancer who who's the
people that's getting cancer if Elon
didn't who is the people that's getting
canceled who is the people that's
getting cancer that's getting canceled
so you can express yourself you could be
yourself a b walked off the field so you
could be yourself me and Kanye relate
yay relate because he could be himself
yeah but that's why that's why he's
asking the question because Elon bought
Twitter for that same exact concept but
you still that's why Elon called Kanye a
B I understand come on now if it was the
oldest would have been off
would have been off of Twitter he just
bought polish I know he did you can't
even express yourself on Twitter for 160
characters I know Elon Posse here make
that better for better expression but it
still doesn't help but God getting
canceled if you say the wrong thing or
if you're a Target like you just said
those who is those who's getting
canceled sir like a lot of people like
who
you want me to list a few of them yeah
listen please
off the top of my head obviously Trump
got canceled okay you know you're the
president you get canceled that's the
point that's exactly what we're talking
about here uh how do they cancel I think
he's off Andrew Tate just got canceled
we just did a massive interview with
Andrew Tate he's like you know who that
is of course I know okay are you in
favor of him getting canceled obviously
not I mean no one's getting canceled man
what do you mean that everyone's getting
canceled I'm saying we need to stop the
prohibited non-canceling it's like on
the same page there baby of course
that's what I'm saying so let me let me
let me read this which which is I just
saw this on Twitter earlier so Adidas
did he lose his bank's account did he
lose two B's in one day no not two B's
okay no but they did cut off Adidas Cuts
ties and the only reason we're bringing
up take this is because you said who's
been canceled so we're answering your
question for you so Adidas cut ties with
yay uh but
ties Vogue and a winter cut ties dropped
by CAA dropped by lawyer stream sales
AirPlay by the way Spotify CEO hasn't
said they're dropping yet they're still
allowing the music to stay on but it's
plummeted restricted from Instagram and
Twitter I saw him post something today
on Instagram which is great stadium
shows canceled documentary show up two
billion dollars last in a day just a
couple days ago uh he said he's only got
120 million dollars left in cash he said
this I think on it was either uh the
Pierce uh Morgan interview was the I
think was Pierce Morgan 120. uh so so
the fact that they target him the way
they did
do you think and you don't have to
answer this you can simply say no or no
comment or just not even answer it do
you think the Tipping Point was what
they call the anti-Semitism comment you
think that was a Tipping Point I thought
you would listen to everyone that got
canceled
oh we can't give that to you as well if
you want to let me give you one baby let
me give you one example you can pull up
a list you know who got canceled you
already said the list I thought he was
running through why they got no no that
was that was Kanye you got cancer but
here obviously we know that let me give
you one name that you'll probably be
very familiar with he gave me the names
honestly we give you two names I thought
he was going to read off it like he read
I'm trying to give you a name right now
for you who already gave me two names
I'm trying to hear what they did and
what happened to him okay what are your
thoughts about your boy the baby getting
canceled after his game all right so
with the details what happened he said
homophobic slurs apparently I'm rolling
live but what happened after what they
do like the details what he just read
off all that what was the
you want to know what happened to the
baby what was the plots man what was the
events in the story that you seeing like
I got canceled just all the stuff you
just read on I mean the baby was jobs
for speaking out loud which I don't
agree with the 30 year old rapper yeah I
was accused of making homophobic remarks
at a music festival rolling loud which
you performed
well this is the whole point of the
conversation is that Elon buying Twitter
Kanye yay buying parlor there's other
help how does that help you just said
about you know what I'm saying how does
that still help maybe if we I'm asking
you how does that I'm gonna ask you a
very direct question yeah what are your
thoughts on the First Amendment freedom
of speech you're familiar with that bro
it can't be no freedom of speech because
you know I mean everything you say it
could get you canceled you just said it
and these guys got canceled no argument
that's the whole conversation is that
people in America today yeah a b should
say whatever he wants to say or be able
to say what everyone say controversial
or not Trump bro opinion is opposite of
the fact so no matter what you say
that's your opinion you should have a
right to your opinion whether right or
wrong we're on the same page opposite of
the fact I'm not saying we're not on the
same thing we just communicate and let
you know I understand where you're
saying
I get it
I get it um
okay so you perform the baby the fact
that he got canceled and the LGBT
community tried to cancel him that had
no sway on you doing a um feature bro I
love the baby okay my brother man you
know God's Gonna always try to cancel
God like us who in a high position or
you know they can't be used or you know
used for someone else capture or game
you know if you play football you're
gonna get CT if you walk off like me
then you probably got hit in ICT
so it's like you know you know what you
eat the damn either way
it's kind of like your opinion
you know it's the true someone else's
opinion
in the other person opinion so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]